mars 1957 au plus fort de la bataille
d'alger
l'avocat et militant nationaliste ali
boumendjel est capturé et torturé puis
assassiné à l'âge de 38 ans plus de
soixante ans après la france reconnaît
la responsabilité de l'armée française
dans cet assassinat
jusqu alors maquillé en suicide une
armée française dont les pouvoirs
militaires et civiles sont deux mois
plus tôt remis aux parachutistes du
général massu
donc c'est pour ça qu'on évoque contart
le rôle de l'armée parce que d'une
certaine façon elle et omnipotente
durant la période en faisant ça c'est
assez commode parce que du coup on évite
de poser la question du rôle politique
et de reposer la question de comment on
en est arrivé à donner autant de
pouvoirs à des années militaire
présentée comme un geste d'apaisement
par emmanuel macron cette reconnaissance
officielle ne va pas assez loin pour
l'avocat et militant des droits de
l'homme mustapha bouchachi
nous apprécions que la france
reconnaisse avoir commis un crime contre
un avocat algérien mais nous pensons que
ça n'est pas suffisant
la france doit reconnaître les crimes
contre l'humanité qu'elle a commis en
algérie pourtant à droite certaines voix
ne croit pas à cet apaisement
le chef de file des républicains au
sénat s'interroge sur la portée de ce
geste
moi je veux bien qu'on fasse la clarté
la vérité sur notre histoire il faut pas
que ça soit à sens unique
ce que je veux dire c'est que j'attends
aussi de l'algérie qu'elle puisse
reconnaître les massacres par exemple
des harkis par dizaines de milliers la
torture aussi sur des français ça doit
être dans les 2 sens pourquier de
l'apaisement
pour malika rahal spécialiste de
l'algérie moderne la construction d'une
histoire commune basée sur des
témoignages multiples est essentiel pour
avancer vers la reconstruction
il ya des façons de raconter ces
histoires ne serait ce qu'en montrant
les destins peu singulier les façons de
s'opposer au cours de l'histoire les
formes de résistance les formes de
résilience à ses fils wayne et ça me
paraît à la fois pas impossible
est absolument nécessaire de produire
cette histoire qui soit à la fois claire
et qui soit à la fois pas dans des
formes de d'exclusion des uns et des
autres suite à la remise par l'historien
benjamin stora du rapport sur la
réconciliation mémorielle entre la
france et l'algérie
le président de la république a affirmé
que ce travail serait approfondie au
cours des prochains mois mon centre et
d'eric lancel vous êtes géopolitologue
essayiste je vais rappeler les titres de
devaux livre géopolitique comprendre les
fractures du monde contemporain aux
éditions foucher et puis les 100 mots de
la guerre aux éditions que sais-je ils
sont récents il y en a beaucoup d'autres
on va tout d'abord parler et bien de
cette de l'algérie mardi donc les
lizards connu par communiqué
l'arrestation la torture et l'assassinât
en 1957 de l'avocat nationaliste ali
boumendjel est ce que c'est un geste
utile pour apaiser les relations avec
alger qui le reconnaît d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui qui salue plus tôt ce geste
oui c'est un geste non seulement utile
mais assez courageux d'une part parce
qu'il ya encore en france beaucoup de
gens qui ont été très marqués ou qui ont
été acteurs de ces événements qui eux
que qualité là la guerre d'algérie 54 à
62 donc ça sujet extrêmement sensible
d'une part d'autre part c'est utile
parce que l'algérie est un pays
relativement proches et même très
proches géographiquement méditerranéen
donc avec lequel il ya des interactions
géopolitique
donc tout cela constitue en quelque
sorte une où nous pousse à la nécessité
de d'une vraie on va dire ça comme ça
réconciliation maintenant comment se
réconcilier en faisant des gestes et en
disant des mots c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce celui ceux d'emmanuel macron
sont à la fois utile et donc le
courageux à la condition bien évidemment
que de l'autre côté on cesse
d'instrumentaliser je ne suis pas en
train de dire que le peuple algérien n'a
pas le droit à revendiquer une véritable
sensibilité et des gestes et des mots
mémorielle de la part de la france jeudi
qu'en revanche le régime au pouvoir
depuis 62 a constamment instrumentaliser
ce qui pouvait lui servir notamment à
usage interne et et là on n'est pas sur
quelque chose sur une dimension très
positive mais savez vous poser la
question de la réciprocité algérienne
notamment en france
coudes et lui réclame du président la
jugeant qu'il reconnaisse les
assassinats de civils commis au nom du
fln le massacre des harkis notamment et
bien le sénateur philippe bas à l'ex
président de la commission des lois ici
est ce que quand même il faut il faut
l'attendre cette réciprocité pour vous
j'en suis tout à fait convaincu alors
réciprocité pardon réciprocité ne vaut
pas équanimité ou égalité totale sûr
qu'il y avait une situation coloniale et
le peuple algérien est en droit de dire
à la france foot et c'est pas nous qui
vous avons colonisés par conséquent le
cadre colonial offrait malheureusement
toutes les conditions pour qu'il y ait
des débordements des crimes voire des
massacres donc il n'y a pas de
réciprocité totale
en revanche il y a effectivement
responsabilité dans un certain nombre de
meurtres et de massacres de la part de
ce qui va devenir le régime algérien ça
c'est vrai donc pour la france les
français les citoyens français et le
peuple français mais c'est vrai aussi
donc encore une fois j'insiste pour le
régime algérien c'est à dire que sans
péché ou s'interdire de d'effectuer des
réformes absolument nécessaire pour le
peuple algérien sous prétexte qu'il y
ait eu colonisation et qu'on n'a pas
encore reçu suffisamment de mots ou de
gestes sans c'est ce que j'appelle et je
le répète de l'instrumentalisation
alors ce geste de l'un france il
s'inscrit aussi dans le cadre des
recommandations du rapport stora ce
n'est pas un acte isolé nous dit
l'elysée s'inscrit dans une
réconciliation des mémoires qu'est-ce
qui peut suivre pour vous il peut suivre
d'abord des voyages mémorial y en a déjà
eu des gestes et des mots parce que
fondamentalement c'est ça qui va se
passer derrière il peut très bien y
avoir la constitution d'une dimension
muséale commune après tout point par un
jour on peut très bien imaginer un musée
commun d'autres rapports l'ouverture
bien sûr des archives
oui c'était accès aux archives sont très
importants absolument à la fois du côté
français du côté algérien et par
ailleurs je pense qu'il faut saluer ce
qu'a fait le grand historien incontesté
dans ses travaux benjamin stora parce
que ils essayent petites touches par
petites touches qui à part pierre de
d'établir un plus petit dénominateur
commun
en quelque sorte un et là encore la
fraîcheur relative voire non relative
avec laquelle son rapport pourtant très
très très modérée est me semble-t-il riz
a été accueillie démontre que on est
encore loin d'une vraie réconciliation
oui il ya eu un accueil
mitigé plus que cela en algérie pour
vous qu'est-ce que quels sont les
blocages aujourd'hui qui persiste en
france comme en algérie pour empêcher
cette réconciliation des mémoires et sur
lequel vous l'avez dit il rapportera 10
est à la fois ni excuse ni repentance
mais beaucoup d'accumulation d' acte
symbolique je dirais que la géopolitique
n'étant jamais très très loin au fond
des questions des considérations de
politique intérieure au moment où le
irak est extrêmement fort entre ce
mouvement de contestation sociale
dix ans après le printemps arabe qui
avait très peu touché d'ailleurs
l'algérie pour des raisons liées à la
guerre civile des années 90 et au trauma
que cela avait laissé mais en tout cas
il ya une contestation permanente et
face à cela les gouvernements algériens
successifs mais qui s'inscrit dans le
même régime en réalité sont extrêmement
sont en difficulté et donc ils
recherchent tout ce qui à l'extérieur
peut leur permettre d'unifier la nation
est en tout cas de se maintenir au
pouvoir et la ans quand on a avec la
france un instrument extrêmement commode
et leur apportera finalement il est
gênant pourquoi parce qu'il propose
c'est une main tendue il propose un
début de vraie réconciliation c'est pas
forcément le moment en tout cas pour une
partie pas tout mais une partie de la
classe politique algérienne certainement
la plus la plus chaude vinolas plus
nationaliste et pour les français et les
blocages aussi alors je pense qu'il ya
des blocages de la part d'une partie de
la population française qui ne souhaite
pas qu'il y ait effectivement des
excuses unilatérale en quelque sorte
même pas d'autre part vous avez encore
des pieds noirs des fils ou des petits
fils de pieds noirs d'une part les
harkis que vous avez très bien mentionné
tout à l'heure qu'il ne faut pas oublier
qu'ils considèrent qu'ils ont été eux
aussi victimes de ces événements et de
sédières et en l'occurrence
historiquement c'est parfaitement exact
alors le communiqué de l'elysée aussi
l'imputent l'arrestation la torture et
l'assassinât d'ali boumendjel à l'armée
à la phrase c'est la suivante au coeur
de la bataille d'alger il fut arrêté par
l'armée française
placé au secret torturé puis assassiné
le 23 mars 1957 et cette phrase elle a
fait réagir l'ancien ministre de la
défense et sénateur de la meuse gérard
longuet écoutez je suis très étonné
parce que c'est cela concerne
directement l'armée française
qui n'étaient pas en algérie présente de
son propre fait mais du fait d'un
gouvernement et je pense que le
président macro aurait été avisé de
juger d'abord le gouvernement qui a
donné des ordres et qui les a couverts
car les militaires ne font jamais
qu'exécuter la politique qu'on leur
demande de mettre en oeuvre donc gérard
longuet estime que l'on fait porter la
responsabilité à l'exécutant à l'armée
et non celui qui a donné les ordres le
gouvernement est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse
je suis totalement d'accord avec cette
analyse dans un état de droit dans une
démocratie authentique et la france
l'est il la france l'était dès 1954 bien
évidemment l'armée est lobé et lobby aux
ordres donc ce sont au pouce et au
pouvoir politique et aux hommes
politiques et aux fins de politique
d'assumer les responsabilités lorsque
les les ordres sont donnés et lorsqu'il
s'agit de crimes bien d assumer pendant
très longtemps voire de manière
imprescriptible sylvia crimes de guerre
ou crimes contre l'humanité en l'espèce
est d'ailleurs la question se pose aussi
aujourd'hui pour le rwanda dont vous
savez que c'est une question extrêmement
brûlant qui revient comme un serpent de
mer
là encore en larmes et exécute les
ordres le pouvoir politique doit assumer
l'intégralité de ses responsabilités
frédéric encel je voudrais que l'on
parle d'un autre sujet de nombreux
sujets dans l'actualité je voudrais
aborder avec vous et bien ce sondage
ifop qui fait beaucoup parler de lui qui
montre que 52% des lycéens français sont
favorables au port de signes religieux
ostensibles dans les établissements 38 %
veulent une loi autorisant le port du
burkini
et ce matin le député la france
insoumise alexis corbière est l invité
de public sénat il s'est exprimé à ce
sujet on écoute et on en parle ensemble
port du burkini ça c'est pas la laïcité
ça notre débat je vois pas ce que ça
vient faire dans la discussion parce que
la loi de 905 pourrait très bien
permettre qu'on aille à la plage avec la
tenue qu'on veut quelque chose qu'on en
pense du pas que j'approuve les débats
sont mal posé moi je pense que le mot de
laïcité que tout le monde utilise de
l'extrême droite à ce gouvernement pour
lui faire dire autre chose
autre chose amen à ce que cet homme ou
devenus extrêmement confus et les gens
ont l'impression que c'est un terme
utilisé terme magnifique un idéal
d'émancipation que je défends pour
simuler unique ont une partie de nos
concitoyens qui notamment ceux de
confession musulmane vienne jeunesse
quand même qui reste assez anti racistes
assez à l'idée que ils veulent pas que
certains de nos concitoyens sont montrés
du doigt donc quelle conclusion je
conclus
on doit en tirer c'est re définir ce
qu'est la laïcité c'est la loi 1905
ces deux premiers articles pas
financement public du culte et liberté
de conscience c'est pourquoi en droit de
critiquer les religions en allant aussi
pratiquer sa religion
il faut arrêter de casser des pieds
après aux citoyens s'ils respectent la
loi sur leurs convictions spirituelles
des amalgames des question mal posée
nous dit alexis corbière qui résume
selon lui dans ce sondage la question de
la laïcité au sujet de la religion
musulmane est ce que pour vous il a
raison non il a tort non je pense que il
a tort parce que ce n'est pas que cela
la laïcité d'abord c'est beaucoup
d'articles de loi il en a cité deux il a
raison il ya beaucoup d'autres articles
de loi d'une part d'autre part l'école
républicaine
elle est depuis la fin du 19e siècle un
avant même la loi de 1905
elle est soumise et heureusement à une
véritable protection elle est concernée
par une véritable protection qui est
celle de la lutte contre le prosélytisme
il ne peut pas y avoir à l'école de la
république de prosélytisme d'ailleurs
c'est vrai sur plan politique et
idéologique et c'est vrai sur le plan
religieux ça c'est le deuxième point
troisième point les signes religieux
ostentatoires vous savez un maillot de
bain c'est une chose un poignard de sic
c'en est une autre pourquoi pas à terme
le poignard des traditionnels des cycles
dans nos écoles
oui bien que on est des cons entre en
réalité dans une forme de communauté
d'acceptation d'une communautarisme eh
bien on fait effectivement oeuvre de
comment dirais-je d'affaiblissement de
la laïcité je pense par conséquent que à
l'école et jusque et y compris au lycée
on doit faire le plus possible pour
limiter le plus possible non pas la
spiritualité mais les signes ostensibles
ostentatoire il faut revenir à la loi de
2004 qui a été qui a été voté par une
écrasante majorité de des sénateurs et
des députés et qui a été approuvée bien
évidemment par le peuple français à
plusieurs reprises d'ailleurs pardon
j'ajoute un point très important
chapeau à la licra de mettre le doigt
sur 7 sur cette problématique parce que
de plus en plus d'organisations
antiracistes sont de nature
communautaire ou communautariste si
chacun chaque clan chaque tribu chaque
confession chaque collectif se met à
défendre exclusivement ses propres
revendications
ses propres droits avec ou sans
guillemets on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
et on ira vers la guerre civile la licra
ne fait pas ça c'est une organisation
universelle universaliste et je pense
qu'il faut lui rendre chapeau c'est un
sondage qui est fait auprès des lycéens
est ce qui vous inquiète est ce que pour
vous il montre une fracture
générationnelle dans l'adhésion à la
conception de la laïcité à la française
on va parler aussi des spécificités de
ces d'haïti alors sinon une fracture un
clivage pourquoi un clivage parce que
les jeunes gens de ce pays et
heureusement
et entre autres grâce à la licité n'ont
jamais connu la guerre civile ils n'ont
jamais connu de cas de figure de
situation extrêmement grave ou aggravée
par des luttes confessionnelles moi qui
sujet politologue j'ai voyagé dans
beaucoup d'états qui ont été marqués ou
de beaucoup de sociétés qui ont été
marqués par des luttes claniques
tribales confessionnel notamment au
proche et au moyen orient et en afrique
subsaharienne vous dire que lorsque on
l'a vu de près ou lorsqu'on l'a vécu on
fait très attention heureusement nos
jeunes concitoyens ne l'ont pas vécue et
par conséquent ils vivent une sorte de
normalité en quelque sorte un section
c'est un acquis quoi et quelque part
c'est un acquis et quand vous demandez
aux gens ce qu'ils pensent de la liste
est la réplique vient beaucoup de gens
vous réponde positivement mais en
réalité de manière presque passive mais
pourquoi parce que heureusement ils ne
connaissent que cela ils sont protégés
par cela dans tous les matins on va pas
demander à tous les écoliers ou les
lycéens ou les citoyens de france de se
lever à 6h pour saluer le drapeau et
pour bénir la laïcité mais parce que on
a envie les bienfaits tous les jours
mais attention elle est fragile et oui
et d'ailleurs le concept de laïcité à la
française il est souvent mal compris à
l'étranger
pas seulement dans les pays où l'islam
est une religion d'état le maroc
l'algérie etc mais aussi dans le monde
anglo saxon qui a taxé on se rappelle il
ya quelques mois encore la politique d'
emmanuel macron d'islamophobe il ya un
véritable fossé culturel pour vous en
très bien à notre culture etc etc autres
pays je dirais pas culturelle je dirais
politique et institutionnelle parce
qu'au fond on fait partie globalement
très schématiquement d'une même culture
mais de l'autre côté de la manche et de
l'atlantique et peut-être même
d'ailleurs du rhin on considère que au
fond ce n'est pas la laïcité à la
française qui qui qui doit prévaloir
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sécularité où la sécularisation
ce sont des sociétés sécularisées
autrement dit
l'étain et il n'y a pas de religion
d'état là pour le coup on se rejoint et
pas de religion d'état de l'état de
manière générale reste neutre mais la
religion fait néanmoins partie de la
société
alors c'est vrai sur les symboles le
dollar c'est bien connu
où on jure sur la bible quand on est
président américain en allemagne vous
payer une partie de vos impôts à des
confessions à vous les choisissez
mais de toute façon une partie de vos
impôts il y aura nécessairement aux
églises en 1905 a marqué une rupture en
france mais vous savez on pourrait
remonter à 13 103 alors je vais vous
épargner philippe iv le bel
mais quand même en 13 103 vous avez un
roi qui quelque part entre guillemets
inaugure le gallicanisme et le
gallicanisme c'est le fait d'avoir perçu
dans les royaumes de france et jusqu'aux
empirer à la république 1 en passant par
napoléon 1er et son sacre d'avoir
privilégié le pouvoir politique est
temporel sur le pouvoir religieux de la
papauté qui à l'époque en europe était
extraordinairement puissant d'oublier
je dirais que c'est alors c'est
peut-être devenu culturel mais je pense
que c'est surtout une question de
tradition politique institutionnelle les
français y tiennent manifestement
beaucoup et je pense que c'est la
laïcité est un rempart contre tous
prodromou prémices de la guerre si des
aléas on va quitter la tradition pour
parler d'un sujet qui monopolisent
l'actualité les politiques en france
comme à l'étranger il ya bien sûr bien
la crise sanitaire l'épineuse question
des vaccins alors que l'agencé
européenne du médicament a indiqué
aujourd'hui avoir lancé l'étude du
vaccin russe spoutnik les russes
annoncent pouvoir livrer 50 millions de
doses à partir du mois de juin
et tout cela s'inscrit dans un contexte
où certains pays d'europe centrale se
tourner vers la chine par exemple la
pologne encore la russie c'est le cas de
la hongrie
et cela sans même attendre
l'homologation des vaccins pour
anticiper distille la pénurie
frédéric encel est ce que cette
situation elle illustre la faiblesse de
l'union européenne à un certain nombre
de derbies qui ont été beaucoup
critiqués pour fournir suffisamment de
vaccins aux états membres
oui et je le regrette comme français
comme européen c'est l'europe est très
puissante sur plans commercial
économique normative industriel très
bien elle ne l'est pas sur le plan pour
l'instant politiques stratégies pour
plein de raisons sur lesquelles on
pourrait revenir mais le traité de rome
ne parlait pas réellement de politiques
et de stratégies d'eau jusque là on a
réussi le les
comment dirais-je dans la dimension
normative économique et quelques parts
sociales et la voilà que ce soft power
concerne pas bien sûr pour l'instant
stratégique et militaire
eh bien ça ne fonctionne pas j'allais
dire non plus et là c'est extrêmement
grave parce que le modèle européen il
risque de se gripper d'autres états qui
pourraient rejoindre l'union européenne
qui voudrait s'allier s'associer à
l'union européenne
ils vont y voir un véritable faiblesse
nos adversaires y compris les systémique
je reprends des thermes à la main d'un
liées à la chine est bien vont en
ricaner et vont considérer que
décidément l'union européenne mais on
peut la balle passait entre guillemets
on peut on peut se se sont moqués de ses
revendications parce que de toute façon
il n'est même pas capable
sur le plan sanitaire et prophylactiques
de de jouer un rôle important et surtout
c'est anormal parce que nous avons
objectivement absolument tout sur le
plan démographique bien sûr ingénieux
rial médical économiques industriels
pour faire face aussi bien sinon mieux
que les russes les américains les
israéliens qui sais-je encore à sète à
ce problème
que s'est il passé si ça marche mais
alors là je pense très sincèrement que
sur le plan administratif au sens
bruxellois du terme on a pris du retard
je pense qu'au départ on a pris du
retard d'une part d'autre part on a
essayé et là c'est un argument qu'on ne
peut pas trop contesté qui est plutôt ja
lire sympathique au sens étymologique du
terme
on a tenté et on a voulu vérifier le
caractère le plus comment dirais-je
enfin le plus prophylactique le plus
efficace mais chacun des vaccins que
quand nous qu'on nous proposait et ça ça
prend du temps
la vérification prudence peut-être aussi
dans ce contexte de la part de la
commission européenne ont peut-être
peut-être mais voyez je peux pas
l'affirmer parce que je ne suis pas
moi-même viroleau ou médecin mais de
toute façon il n'est pas compréhensible
pour beaucoup de citoyens européens que
nous ayons pris autant de retard par
rapport au retard par rapport à des
puissances qui notamment sur le plan
économique démographique et un janin je
pense à la russie sont en principe
derrière nous il ya aussi certains pays
européens l'autriche et le danemark qui
vont s'associer avec israël ça a été
signé aujourd'hui pour produire des
vaccins notamment de deuxième génération
cela pour mieux se préparer à la
mutation du virus est ce que c'est
justifié c'est une décision qui a été
très critiqué par paris ce sont des
tentations de sécession à ce sont les
mots de jean yves le drian
alors ce sont des mots forts mais qui ne
sont pas illégitimes et qui illustre le
problème dont on vient de parler lorsque
la hongrie fait cavalier seul sur les
sanctions vis-à-vis de la russie par
exemple vous à vis de la turquie
lorsque la pologne et les pays baltes
font plus ou moins cavalier seul sur des
thématiques ayant pas très éloigné non
plus de la russie lorsque tel ou tel
pays décident de ne pas respecter telle
dimension telle initiative européenne
évidemment c'est toute la construction
européenne qui en étaient branlée mais
le problème c'est que lorsque vous dites
aux autrichiens mais regardez on a la
possibilité avec un état ami est de plus
en plus proche du refuge alliés parce
que là aussi c'est l'illustration de la
des rapports géopolitiques le faire à
l'autriche entretient d'excellents
rapports avec qui serait la république
tchèque russie et d'autres pays
notamment à l'est de l'union européenne
décide
lorsque pardon vous dit un citoyen
autrichien m'écouter là ça va aller plus
vite ça va être plus efficace si sur ce
thème là sur cette initiative là on
fonctionne avec israël ou avec des
martiens ou que sais-je encore pourquoi
les autrichiens il verrait il y verrait
à redire d'ailleurs les enquêtes
d'opinion que j'ai pu constater ces
toutes dernières heures en autriche
étaient plutôt favorables à cette
initiative gouvernementale mais
évidemment tout cela affaiblit l'union
européenne en tant que future puissance
alors on va continuer à parler d'israël
et puis aussi des territoires
palestiniens parce qu'il ya une décision
qui a été prise hier la cour pénale
internationale a annoncé hier
l'ouverture d'une enquête sur des crimes
présumés dans les territoires
palestiniens une décision qui a été
assez logiquement un salut par le fatah
de mahmoud abbas
écoutez bien la réaction de jibril
rajoub secrétaire du comité central du
fatah
je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous marquons un
moment historique pour notre lutte nous
apprécions nous viendrons et nous
coopérons avec la cpi et nous espérons
que la communauté internationale
qu'opera également d
plutôt que de tenter d'entraver
l'enquêté l'interrogatoire contre les
politiques israéliens ce fasciste et
raciste à l'encontre du peuple
palestinien et de son côté benjamin
netanyahu a dénoncé lui une décision
anti sémite
et puis les etats unis ont eux aussi
dénoncé fermement cette enquête sur quoi
elle va porter cette enquête sera
finalement à frédéric encel alors elles
portent d'abord la cour pénale
internationale sous c'est quelqu'un qui
est qui a été créée en 2002 cette en
quelque sorte autoproclamé peu
compétente sur des crimes éventuellement
graves leurs crimes de guerre ou autres
types de crimes qui auraient été qui se
serait produit notamment lors des
différents conflits entre israël de la
ramasse d'une part éventuellement israël
et des groupes palestiniens cette fois
ci en cisjordanie dans de l'autre côté
d'autre part alors la question est la
suivante est ce que la cpi est
effectivement qualifier à partir du
moment où elles mêmes se reconnaît comme
qualifiés elle a le droit d'intervenir
après vous avez deux problèmes le
premier c'est que israël n'est pas ne
reconnaît pas la cpi en tout cas n'est
pas membre du statut de rome ça c'est le
premier point deuxième point la cpi dit
attention il y à des crimes de guerre
potentiel à la fois du côté de l'armée
d'israël et de certains groupes
palestiniens
mais qui sont ces groupes palestiniens
vous avez le ramasse potentiellement
puisqu'il s'agissait bien sûr de la
bande de gaza de l époque donc d'israël
façon fin de la guerre de l'été 2014
dans la bande de gaza ses
téléspectatrices et c'est exactement
et d'autre part il peut aussi y avoir
une stigmatisation de groupes
palestiniens armés
c'est très spécifiquement ce qui est dit
très clairement ce qui est dit par là
par la cpi or nous sommes dans un agenda
politique israélien et palestinien
absolument crucial oui les prochaines
élections israéliennes ont lieu fin mars
donc netanyahu de toute façon il ne peut
pas dire autre chose ne serait-ce que
d'un point de vue politique aux
politiciens que ce qu'il a dit
effectivement ces dernières heures quand
une situation délicate pour vous dans
qu'est ce qui est sûr saluer de haut
niveau interne en israël l'ouverture de
cette enquête
alors tant qu'ils refusent
catégoriquement en traitant la cpi tous
les non au contraire quelque part il
continue
jouer le rôle qu'ils préfèrent et qui
lui rapporte le plus de suffrages c'est
à dire le rôle de bouclier face aux
pressions extérieures ça a été le cas
avec obama pendant huit ans le ch a dit
ça ya pas si longtemps que ça
c'est le cas face à d'autres chefs
d'état ou de gouvernement hélas avec le
cas face à la cpi il à l'israélien se
retrouve globalement y compris
d'ailleurs la plupart des travaillistes
plutôt sur cette position-là de refus
mais si il devait faire des gestes là
pour le coup ils seraient stigmatisés
par le centre et la droite quant aux
palestiniens pour la première fois
depuis janvier 2005 ils vont voter et
ils vont voter de manière en principe
transparentes et démocratiques
et là vous avez un jeu extrêmement
compliqué entre l'autorité palestinienne
légales légitimes dont on vient
d'entendre un représentant reconnu par
les nations unies et le ramasse qui lui
est considéré par la plupart des
chancelleries comme un groupe terroriste
mais mais qui dispose quand même d'un
d'un poids politique donc autrement dit
on et je me résume on est sur un sur un
jeu à trois il sera l autorité
palestinienne et ramasse dans cette
histoire un jeu à 3 qu'on va suivre
attentivement merci beaucoup frédéric
encel pour tous vos éclairages et je
reprécise 1 pour conclure les titres de
deux de vos ouvrages récents
géopolitique comprendre les fractures du
monde contemporain aux éditions foucher
et les 100 mots de la guerre c'est chez
que sais-je merci beaucoup c'était
passionnant